today's do-gooder or drew gooder as
we're calling them
he is 18-year-old justin gavin from
brooklyn new york
he saw a burning car on the street with
a mother
and her three children inside and
without hesitation he risked his own
life
to pull each one of them out of that
burning car
into safety
please welcome right here in the studio
justin gavin
[Applause]
i am really star struck to meet a real
life hero
mean i wouldn't call myself a hero i
just thought i just thought i just did
what was right
so i'm not gonna call myself hero but
may i ask
when you see that what goes on
inside of your head and body is it a
trajectory that just
happens are you thinking what what does
it feel like
um to me i feel like at that moment
it was no thinking like i just thought
what was right i knew if i was in that
situation i definitely want someone to
do exactly
what i did but not all people was like
that but i'm just glad i was there at
the right place
at the right time you really were so
what what were you you were just walking
down the street on your
merry way um yeah i was i ended up
running to everyone
and i just saw a bunch of cars and they
were just honking their horns
and it was yelling out the car's on fire
the cars are fired and i was clueless i
didn't know what was happening
so i i actually did see the car after a
while and i'm like
oh get out the car get out the car your
car was on fire and nobody was running
towards the car i
was trying to do anything to help out so
i just ran to this car
and do you reach in at that point do you
open doors
or what what are you doing um i told the
oldest which is nine years old to like
unbuckle her seatbelt a sibling seatbelt
it was nine four and one i believe
then it was it was scary for me because
i didn't know what was going to happen
i thought at that time i was actually
going to lose my life and they were
going to lose their life
but if i did lose my life i would lose
my life trying to save somebody else so
it was
[Applause]
i mean do you believe in angels
yeah i do i do a lot of people call me
an angel but i just feel like
i just did the right thing you really
are
an angel and i i mean i just i believe
there are humans masquerading
as angels i believe that there is
capacity
in a human but to sit here and hear your
story
i mean you are what i think people
need to believe in we need to believe in
angels in human form
i i i just okay so everyone ended up
okay
yeah everybody ended okay to mom at one
point she couldn't really breathe
correctly but
the um paramedics helped out gave her
more oxygen so she can actually start
breathing correctly and
she was just grateful that i was there
the kids was grateful
um it was i'm i was just happy that they
were all safe i'm glad that i was safe
i'm glad everybody at that air in the
area was safe
nobody really got home but i mean you
saved an entire family
i i i just i'm sorry i'm i'm really i am
just in awe of you and um the mayor
of um waterbury connecticut
went where this happened when he heard
what you did
he wanted to do something for you so he
asked me
to give you this proclamation of the
town
in honor of your bravery um
and that's not all when we heard um that
you had a particular favorite basketball
player he also heard
what you did and he had this to say it's
carmelo anthony
what yo justin it's carmelo anthony here
bruh
i heard about your story man i want to
let you know how inspiring and
courageous you are man you're a true
true hero you've inspired me man and i'm
so inspired to have someone like you
supporting me throughout my career um i
appreciate it more than you even know
i also heard you a sneaker head like me
so we're going to hook you up with some
joint brands
uh merch as a small thank you for the
big things that you've been doing man
um and that you continue to do so you
know i'll leave you with this
um you know just keep pushing man keep
persevering
keep making your family proud again
thank you
for what you did and just know we all
rooting for you man
and know you're going to continue to do
great things
peace stay mellow
[Applause]
we also found out that you're a fan of
the brooklyn nets and they
wanted to say thank you too so
oh so we have hooked you all
up we're getting you season passes go to
all the games the players are excited to
meet you
and really there's just not enough that
we can do here at this show there's no
way
to sort of monetize or match your act of
saving an entire family but we just
wanted to
start in some way and everybody joined
in
and we just are in awe of you honestly
thank you so much thank you justin
you